bonjour merci est d'être avec nous alors
amazon dément une victoire seulement un
peu plus de la moitié 55% des salariés
ont voté donc il n'y aura pas de
syndicat votre première réaction
à écouter au niveau 2 les états unis il
ya un réel problème nous en france on
n'a pas ce problème là mais nous allons
surprend au niveau des syndicats
amazon la problématique qui se passait
réellement
enfin on comprend pas nous en france
pourquoi et aux états unis on n'a pas le
droit à ça dit quoi
alors justement vous parlez de la france
que la situation est similaire aux états
unis et en france
il ya des similitudes notamment au
niveau des conditions de travail
enfin les salariés ils ont des réels
problèmes d'être est d'aider 13,6 des
problèmes les arrêts maladie les arrêts
de travail le salaire en ce moment on
est en pleine négociation on demande la
valorisation de notre salaire voilà on
est toujours un peu mise à l'écart non
rejoint réellement les travailleurs
américains on sait qu'ils endurent
vraiment un
ils ont un réel problème le marketing
avec la zone a fait fort là-bas et donc
du coup se sont retrouvés vraiment avec
1,8 faire valoir qu'au départ il avait
eu des signatures pour pouvoir avoir la
possibilité de créer un syndicat
ce qui aurait été vraiment bien pour les
travailleurs minc et que craint amazon
avec des syndicats les travailleurs se
rassemblent que les travailler coeur au
niveau d'un la zone puissent avoir une
position ne pose ce n'est pas une
position de force mais un réel à réel
contrepoids sur ce que amazon fait pas
seulement aux états unis ou en france
mais ils on aurait réellement peur que
bas et les travailleurs puissent se
rassembler et puisse montrer leur lot
réelles conditions de travail
encore une fois je fais bien la part des
choses lorsque s'y passe aux etats-unis
et en france et nous en france on a des
syndicats ja voilà qu'on n'a pas de réel
problème même s'il ya beaucoup de choses
à dire au niveau du des officines
syndicales qui sont mises en place et si
nous en france mais aux états unis où il
ya un réel problème et ils ont vraiment
vraiment besoin d'un syndicat et on voit
qu amazon a fait le vraiment le forcing
alors que ben apparemment au niveau du
gouvernement américain avec jean-yves
hayden est béni par les sondeurs ils
sont ils voudraient ils voulaient qu'il
voulait proposer il voulait qu'un
syndicat se met en place quoi année mais
la trash merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
militant syndical et salariés d'amazon
en france marcia vous